mr. steric I told you not to disturb me
what have we here Crawford starix full
organization seven henchmen each
controlling the pillars of London
society rupert Ferris regulates the
industries with a steel rod and an iron
fist the machine fixed
Carl Attaway owns all transportation in
London the ebb and flow of the city's
traffic at her fingertips David Brewster
and dr. Elliot's first science and
medicine to their very limits
unfortunately it appears I've ruined the
orbit with terrifying results Philip
twopenny
and James Rennell crippled the masses to
grow their fortunes and finally Maxwell
brought London's criminal mastermind so
what's the plan to free future
generations from a city ruled by
Templars then shall we yes once Derek is
done to the city
we will free London from start we take
of hysterics gangs the [ __ ] is
control we welcome all new ones
as of this moment you all work for us
I'm here to see mr. Roth weapons no
thank you
I've got my home
if surrounds the potion
who believes they can solve all the
world's woes with a flick of a blade
we're not playing games anymore Roth
or did you accomplish boy you will not
stop staring our city will die once more
for all times sake
don't die
well we seem to have made an unscheduled
stop
since Creed syndicate
you